alors vous avez peut-être déjà entendu
dire que la physique théorique est
actuellement dominé par deux théories à
savoir la relativité générale qui parle
de la structure de l'espace temps à très
grande échelle et la mécanique quantique
qui parle des interactions entre les
particules à très petite échelle mais
étrangement ces deux théories au succès
empirique incroyable sont aussi et
surtout incompatibles en particulier
l'application naïve des principes de la
mécanique quantique à la courbure de
l'espace temps semble inéluctablement
conduire à des infinis impossible
interpréter des idées radicalement
nouvelles semblent indispensables pour
espérer unifier les deux théories les
plus couronnés de succès de la physique
la tentative la plus aboutie aujourd'hui
en tout cas celles qui bénéficient du
plus de chercheurs et aussi du plus de
publicité elle s'appelle la théorie des
cordes
la théorie des cordes son unité c'est de
reprendre un peu les choses à zéro et de
dire finalement le monde n'est pas fait
de particules mais il est fait de petits
objets ni dimensionnelle qui sont des
petites cordes et qui comme les
particules peuvent se balader interagir
se désintégrer fusionner et c'est
aujourd'hui la théorie des cordes celle
approche la plus développée mais elle
est encore loin de pouvoir prétendre à
être la théorie du tout ok merci david
aujourd'hui on va pousser la réflexion
un peu plus loin on va se demander si la
théorie des cordes peut un jour
candidater à être une théorie du tout
voire même si cette théorie est une
théorie non courants alors avant d'aller
plus loin vers une analyse plus fine de
la notion de théorie même si j'en ai
déjà beaucoup beaucoup parlé
je vais commencer par quelques remarques
et sur l'idée de science pas réfutation
car bien qu'elles correspondent à une
pauvre caricature de l'épistémologie du
philosophe karl popper
il s'agit néanmoins d'un principe très
répandue chez les scientifiques et les
étés titien ou plutôt je vais vous
passez ces extraits monsieur fille
explique très bien les limites de la
science par réfutation mais je vois pas
le problème vraiment d'un site à une
théorie qu'elle fait une prédiction la
prédiction est fausse ça veut dire que
la théorie est fausse c'est comme ça
c'est logique modus tollens tout ça tout
ça
du point de vue logique tu as
prédictions ce n'est pas du tout une
implication tout simple et propre
théorie flèche observations en réalité
si une prédiction il ya une sorte d'
implication son antécédent mener
amener une théorie tout seul mais
toujours une vaste de conjonction de
théorie et d'hypothèses dont tous genres
parmi tout ça il ya bien la théorie ou
l'hypothèse qu'on veut tester mais il ya
aussi tout le reste toutes les autres
hypothèses qu'on appelle généralement
les hypothèses auxiliaires et c'est donc
seulement en prenant tout ça ensemble
qu'on peut déduire certaines
observations expérimentales et si
l'observation des paquebots forme et
bien du point de vue logique ça implique
seulement la fausseté de la conjonction
tout entière c'est-à-dire la fausseté de
moi un élément de celle ci et on ne sait
pas lequel ou lesquels ça peut être la
théorie tester bien sûr mais ça peut
être aussi n'importe laquelle des
théories hypothèse auxiliaires le point
important est que je veux souligner
c'est qu'on ne peut jamais testé une
théorie isolément et ça c'est
particulièrement clair dans le cas de la
théorie des cordes
en effet la théorie des cordes seule ne
suffit même pas à déterminer la manière
dont les cordes de la théorie vibre et
du coup elles impliquent rien quand on
propriété physique des particules
les cordes elle vibre et donc elles vont
vibrer dans les dimensions l'espace deux
cas la bio et la manière dont les cordes
fibre détermine les propriétés des
particules qu'on va trouver dans la
théorie ça veut dire que si moi je
commence à faire de la théorie des
cordes en choisissant un espace de
cabillaud et que mon voisin il fait de
la théorie des cordes et qu'il en prend
un autre on va fabriquer deux théories
ayant des propriétés physiques
différentes ayant des particules
différentes et donc il ya autant de
théorie des cordes possible que de
manière de choisir l'espace deux cas la
bio le problème c'est que entre le choix
de l'espace deux cas la bio et puis les
autres choix qu'il faut faire pour qu'on
fabrique une théorie des cordes
c'est ce qu'on appelle le problème du
choix du vide on se rend compte qu'on
peut fabriquer peut-être jusqu'à 10
puissance en théorie des cordes
différentes pour les critiques de la
théorie des cordes cette abondance de
choix ça rend la théorie complètement
inutilisable si vous avez 10 puissance
en version de votre théorie ça veut dire
que chaque fois vous essayez de faire
une prédiction expérimental vous avez 10
puissance en prédiction expérimental et
donc dans ces conditions comment on peut
tester la théorie si demain quelqu'un à
se pointe avec un résultat expérimental
nouveau vous allez toujours trouvé une
tetra chier de théorie des cordes qui
sont capables d'expliquer ce résultat
expérimental et donc même pour les plus
virulents critiques du coup la théorie
des cordes est pas une science puisqu'on
peut pas l'attesté expérimental et donc
si l'on en croit le formalisme
naïve de la science par réfutation la
théorie des cordes ne serait pas une
théorie mais en fait à bien y réfléchir
ce problème n'est absolument pas
spécifique à la théorie des cordes le
même problème apparaît également pour
des théories pourtant célébré par les
sciences comme étant des modèles de
théories scientifiques comme la théorie
de la gravité de newton ou comme la
théorie de la relativité restreinte sur
laquelle s'appuie à la fois la
relativité générale et la mécanique
quantique moderne il y a quelques années
un groupe de chercheurs italiens a fait
des mesures qui semblait indiquer que
des neutrinos se baladant entre la
suisse et l'italie se déplacer plus vite
que la lumière ce qui a le mauvais goût
de contredire les fondements de la
théorie de la relativité restreinte
du coup face à ces observations
troublante on pouvait se dire ou bien
que la vénérable théorie de la
relativité restreinte et erronées ou
bien qu'il y à une couille dans le
potage de l'accélérateur de particules
et de fait les physiciens en général
considéré que le deuxième cas était bien
plus probable que le premier et il avait
raison il s'agissait bien des erreurs de
mesure dont on a pu identifier la source
quelque temps plus tard donc non très
clairement quand des observations
contredire une théorie la méthode
scientifique ce n'est pas de rejeter la
théorie parce qu'en réalité
l'observation en question ne contredit
jamais la théorie tout seul mais
toujours une vaste conjonction de
théorie et d'hypothèses auxiliaires
notamment des hypothèses concernant les
circonstances de l'observation elles
mêmes hypothèses qui peuvent être
beaucoup moins crédible que la théorie
prétendument contredite par cette
observation et oui parce qu'à bien y
réfléchir pour vraiment devenir
prédictive même des théories comme la
relativité restreinte se doivent de
s'appuyer sur toutes sortes de
paramètres additionnels notamment
concernant la fiabilité des instruments
de mesure or pourvu qu'il y à 1000
composants dans ces instruments
ce qui est souvent largement le cas on
aura facilement au moins 1000 paramètres
à décrire pour pouvoir prédire
or mille paramètres ça nous fera au
moins de puissance 1000 prédiction
possible en fonction des valeurs des
différents paramètres
à côté de cela les 10 puissance en
version de la théorie des cordes
paraissent en fait être un choix
restreint
bref même les théories célébrer de la
physique ne prédisent en fait rien du
moins à elle seule elle ne précise rien
elles ne sont pas réfutable elles ne
sont pas des théories scientifiques ou
sens neige
de la science par réfutation
alors si je vous raconte tout ça ce
n'est bien sûr pas pour critiquer la
physique où les théories de la physique
ne s'agit absolument pas de demander aux
physiciens d'arrêter de qualifier leurs
théories de théorie j'espère davantage
vous montrer qu'il ya énormément de
subtilité derrière la notion de théories
scientifiques qui me semble beaucoup
trop ignorée à la fois par les
scientifiques et par les vulgarisateurs
scientifiques hashtags c'est compliqué
mais surtout mesuré la difficulté de
définir ce qu'est une théorie me semble
être une étape nécessaire pour vraiment
apprécier la complétude de la pensée
bayésienne et l'élégance du formalisme
épistémologique de l'informatique
solomonov en fait la plus grande
contribution de ce logo nov
c'est peut-être d'avoir fourni une
définition incroyablement judicieuse au
mot théorie et pour comprendre cette
notion que je vais appeler théorie à la
solomonoff il me faut insisté sur trois
points très importants dont on a déjà
posé les briques dans les épisodes
précédents et de leur première partie de
cette vidéo
ces trois briques qu'on va développer
par la suite sont premièrement on
considère que les données sont une suite
de beats deuxièmement les théories qu'on
considère doivent toujours parié et
troisièmement les théories qu'on
considère doivent être calculable
accepter ces trois points et accepter en
plus le bail à nice mme revient
essentiellement à accepter l'induction
de solomonoff plus ou moins le problème
de la priory universel de sur neuf dont
on parlera la prochaine fois
le premier point on en a déjà long
dans les épisodes 26 et 27 si on accepte
la thèse de church turing ou si l'on
reconnaît le succès de la digitalisation
notamment dans le cadre des technologies
de l'information
alors force est d'admettre que les
données auxquelles nous et nos machines
avons accès sont équivalentes ou au
moins quasi équivalente à des données
numérisées en particulier une suite de
bits
c'est ainsi que sans perte de
généralités solomonov considéra des
données de la sorte est d'ailleurs juste
pour insister sur la généralité des
données numérisées et du problème de
l'induction qui consiste à compléter de
telles données les données brutes étudié
aujourd'hui en sciences sont
essentiellement des enregistrements
d'onde qu'elle soit électromagnétiques
électronique ou mécanique
typiquement les astrophysiciens ont
passé leur temps à analyser des photos
du ciel dans toutes sortes de longueur
d'onde
tandis que les biologistes vont utiliser
des lasers et des caméras pour séquencer
des morceaux d'adr
or ces images sont souvent numériser ou
au moins numérisables c'est ainsi que
beaucoup de données brutes produite par
les sciences ne sont finalement rien
d'autre que des suites de beats en
mettant bout à bout ces bi en ajoutant
des métadonnées elle-même numérisé qui
décrivent par exemple le processus à
travers lequel les nombres ont été
obtenus nous se trouve alors finalement
avec une très longue suite de beats tout
comme la longue suite de beats que
chaque chercheur télécharge quand ils
cherchent à lire un article scientifique
sur internet ou comme celle que votre
ordinateur reçoit après chaque requête
que vous faites sur internet et que
votre ordinateur traite pour ensuite
vous afficher une page web ou une vidéo
youtube
ainsi on se retrouve finalement dans le
même formalisme que celui de l'épisode
33 chercher quelles théories sont
crédibles
ça revient ainsi à déterminer celle qui
colle avec la suite de bits ainsi
collectées
le deuxième point est sans doute
à 100 ou du moins celui dont on a encore
trop peu parlé jusque là selon ce
deuxième point dans le cadre de
solomonoff une théorie se doit de parier
sur tout donné futur qu'on peut imaginer
avoir observé pour comprendre
l'importance de ce second point il
suffit de regarder du côté de l'équation
fondamentale du bdia nisme à savoir la
formule deux pays
cette formule du savoir fait intervenir
des termes appelés vraisemblance des
données selon différentes théories qui
s'écrivent p2 des sachants t ou des
ailes a donné était est la théorie mais
alors pour que cette formule du savoir
s'applique en toutes circonstances il
faut absolument que tout théorique et
qu'on considère a signé une probabilité
a tout donné possiblement observable des
ca en termes mathématiques s'en revient
à dire que la théorie t doit définir une
loi de probabilité
sur l'ensemble des suites binaire fini
autrement dit il faut que étant donné la
théorie t pour tout donner dès qu'on
puisse calculer un nombre entre 0 et 1
qui correspond à la probabilité de la
donner des selon la théorie t et il faut
aussi que les nombres ainsi calculé
respectent les lois des probabilités
dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 2 en
langage plus courants ceci revient à
dire que toute théorie était conforme au
formalisme bayésiens doit nécessairement
parier sur tout donner dès possiblement
observable en particulier une théorie by
then they ne peut pas suspendre son
jugement
elle ne doit pas dire je ne sais pas une
théorie parisienne doit parier
et comme les théories à la somme 9
doivent être des théories bayésienne
elles aussi doivent parier sur tout
donné possiblement observable en cela
non la théorie des cordes n'est pas une
théorie à la solomonoff après tout tout
seul elle est incapable de parler quoi
que ce soit par exemple sur la masse au
repos de l'électron ou par exemple sur
le nombre total de décès confirmés du
comité 19 en 2020 tel qu'il sera
rapportée par le site world aux metteurs
au 1er janvier 2021
par exemple
beaucoup de scientifiques ou de
vulgarisateur scientifique insiste
énormément sur la notion de théorie et
sur de potentielles distinction entre
les mots théorie postule à axione
hypothèses ou encore thèse mais
étrangement non seulement je n'ai jamais
fait de telles distinctions et
d'ailleurs dû se fit non plus mais
surtout le cadre de somme 9 non plus et
qui plus est la notion de théorie à la
solomonoff échoué à qualifier les
théories les plus importantes des
sciences de théorie pour comprendre
cette tension entre le langage de
solomonoff et le langage courant des
scientifiques
on peut reprendre l'exemple de la
relativité restreinte bien y réfléchir
cette théorie défini en fait des règles
de transition entre différents états
successifs de l'univers dès lors pour
qu'on puisse prédire la mesure de la
vitesse des neutrinos de l'expérience
opéra il nous faut en savoir plus sur
l'état physique de l'univers et en
particulier sur la qualité des
instruments de mesure au moment de la
mesure
faute de telles données la théorie de la
relativité restreinte seul ne peut
prédire à rien elle ne fait même pas
paris elle s'abstient de parier mais du
coup la relativité restreinte ne peut
pas être recrutés pour toute observation
on peut concocter une explication
haddock en faisant des hypothèses
auxiliaire sur l'état physique de
l'univers et bien souvent il suffit même
de convoquer des explications haddock
concernant les appareils de mesure si la
relativité restreinte n'est pas aux
standards du bail ziani sme c'est en
fait pour les mêmes raisons que celles
qui font qu'elle n'est pas non plus aux
standards de la science par réfutation
mais alors parce que la relativité
restreinte de paris rien n'est pas clair
comment sacré danse peut être calculé et
surtout comment cette créance doit être
modifiée suite par exemple à la mesure
de la vitesse des neutrinos de
l'expérience opéra en tout cas le balsa
nisme ne semble pas fournir d'outils
pour mesurer la crédence de théorie qui
ne parie pas et en un sens ça tombe bien
puisque de telles théories nous disent
finalement rien des observations qu'on
aimerait prédire ceci étant dit il est
en fête se passe est difficile de
transformer la relativité restreinte en
une théorie à la solomonoff en effet il
suffit de compléter ces théories avec
une description probabiliste d état
physique est probable de l'univers en
l'occurrence si on insinue une
probabilité 95% au fait que les
instruments de l'expérience opéra
fonctionne comme il devrait fonctionner
et si dans les 5% restant à peu près
n'importe quelles observations peut-être
est alors la relativité restreinte plus
cette description probabiliste d état
physique probable de l'univers forme une
théorie à la soul man of en tout cas
concernant les données collectées par
l'expérience opéra en effet cet ensemble
paris désormais à 95 % que la mesure
fait sera un nombre légèrement inférieur
à la vitesse de la lumière aux
imprécisions de mesures prennent alors
petit aparté rapide il est tout à fait
possible de définir des théories
bayésienne restreinte un sous-ensemble
des données possiblement observable il
suffit d'ignorer toutes les données au
sujet desquels ces théories ne précise
rien mais de telles théories ne pourront
pas être mis au même plan que les
théories à la solomonoff qui elle parie
sur tout qui plus est le paradoxe de
stein nous dit que ce genre de
restrictions est en fait statistiquement
inadmissible mais bon il faudrait une
vidéo complète dédiée à ce formidable
paradoxe
l'exemple de l'expérience opéra illustre
en fait un phénomène plus général dans
la construction des théories
scientifiques
en pratique il est ainsi de coutume de
distinguer les états de l'univers des
lois de l'univers
il faut dire que comme la place avait
remarqué la place les lois de newton ont
été particulièrement en réussite pendant
des siècles
si bien qu il semblait qu'il ne manquait
qu'une description des états de
l'univers pour que des prédictions
puisse découler des lois de newton mais
en 1936 en introduisant la machine
universelle qui porte son nom
le mathématicien alan turing à montrer
l'absurdité d'une distinction nette
entre les lois d'un univers et les états
de celui ci en effet intuitivement il
est tentant de penser que les règles de
fonctionnement d'une machine
ces lois sont très différentes des
données qu'on lui fournit que l'on
pourrait naturellement comparé à l'état
de la machine
cependant turing a justement montrer que
toute règle d'une machine pouvait être
décrite comme les données d'une machine
universel
à côté des autres données de la machine
initial al'inverse les données d'une
machine peuvent être incorporés comme
les règles d'une autre machine qui ne
disposerait de plus aucune donnée
initiale ces trois machines qu'on
obtiendrait serait alors indiscernable
d'un point de vue algorithmique en vertu
de l'universalité des machine de turing
il n'y aurait pas de raison de dire que
les règles de l'ue ne sont plus
fondamentale que celle des autres
il y en ait finalement de même pour les
théories usuel de la physique et les
états physiques de l'univers la
frontière entre les deux est en fait
extrêmement poreuse pour prendre un
exemple
alors quelle chaîne avait considéré que
la constante cosmologique était une loi
de l'univers il est courant pour les
physiciens moderne de mettre ce terme à
droite de l'équation est d'interpréter
tout à coup cette constante cosmologique
comme une caractéristique de l'état
physique de notre univers actuel
typiquement appelée énergie noire en
glissant une quantité de gauche à droite
on avait transformé une loi en état plus
troublant encore la théorie des cordes
est ainsi déclinée en au moins 10
puissance sans variante une part
géométrie de l'espace de calais billard
alors que certains vont se demandait
lesquels de ces variantes est la loi de
l'univers d'autres envisagent que toutes
ses variantes existent dans un multivers
et que notre univers dispose d'un état
physique qui correspond à l'une de ses
variantes
un dernier exemple marquant est celui de
la seconde loi de la thermodynamique
c'est le caniche times a qualifié de
suprême cette loi a longtemps été vu
comme une loi de l'univers cependant
certains physiciens comme sean carole
propose une interprétation qui peut
paraître plus simple cette seconde loi
ne serait pas loin de l'univers ce
serait en fait davantage une conséquence
de la très faible entropie de l'état
physique présent surtout en fait de
l'état physique passé de notre univers
dans tous ces exemples on voit qu'on
peut passer très facilement des lois
physiques aux états physiques de
l'univers sans changer quoi que ce soit
ou propriétés prédictive de la
combinaison loi plus états à l'instar de
turing solomonoff nous invite en fait à
considérer que cette distinction entre
loi et est un est en fait inexistante
dit autrement selon seulement 9 une
théorie doit parler à la fois des lois
et des états physiques de sorte que à
elle seule elle parvienne à toujours
parié de théorie à la somme 9 pour
parier et ça ce sera absolument critique
pour comprendre le rasoir d'occam dont
on parlera la prochaine fois
en fait il existe des matches
elle a parié notamment le cerveau humain
que celui ci soit aidée de théories
scientifiques ou non pour savoir c'est
une observation et crédible sachant
l'état des connaissances en physique à
la fois les connaissances sur les lois
physiques et sur l'état physique de
l'univers on peut s'adresser au cerveau
des scientifiques
ainsi si on dit à une astronome que
jupiter a changé de sens de rotation cet
astronome pourra rétorquer si ceux-ci
lui paraît crédible ou non est très
probablement
elle dira que non ça ne lui paraît pas
crédible du tout si on demande une
biologiste si le tyrannosaure dansaient
pour séduire les femelles
elle répondra probablement avec un
marqueur de modestie épistémique pomme
probablement peut être probablement pas
quelque chose comme ça enfin si on
demande à une sociologue de prédire si
l'on observera une diminution des
suicides dans les cinq ans à venir
elle à répondre à beaucoup
d'incertitudes serait que ce cas
répondra mais probablement qu'il
utilisera le mot probablement 6 et paris
sont possibles c'est que les cerveaux
des scientifiques contiennent une
combinaison des lois probable d état
physique probable d'autres univers et de
puissance de calcul qui permet de
combiner tout ça pour effectuer des
paris ainsi ces cerveaux de
scientifiques ne sont pas si différents
de théorie à la solomonoff quoi que
contrairement à nos cerveaux les
théories à la somone off se doivent de
respecter les lois des probabilités
alors on a vu que des théories
comme la relativité restreinte n'étaient
pas des théories à la salle olof et
avait ainsi dû mal à se conformer aux
formalismes bayésiens néanmoins si on
sort du cadre du bail à nice mme
n'est-il pas tout de même un moyen
pragmatique pour prétendre que la
relativité restreinte est en un sens
crédible n'est-il pas quelque chose à
retenir des bêtises que disait le lait
de 2016 l'analogie avec les librairies
de code semble ici très pertinente
ces librairies sont souvent utilisés
pour construire des codes exécutables
cependant ces librairies seul ne sont
pas exécutables elles ne sont que des
blocs de lego qui permettent des
constructions plus complète d'une
certaine manière il en va de même pour
la relativité restreinte les lois de
newton les équations de maxwell est la
relativité générale la mécanique
quantique et toutes ces lois identifiés
par la physique
ces lois sont comparables à des libres
et de code sur lesquels il est utile de
s'appuyer pour construire des théories à
la solomonoff ok mais pensez maintenant
deux librairies différentes qui
permettent de trier des tableaux y at il
vraiment un sens à considérer que l'une
de ces librairies et plus crédible que
l'autre ça paraît un peu vite de sens
il s'agirait plus de déterminer laquelle
est plus utile disons pour différents
cas d'application mais alors de la même
manière que la notion de crédibilité
d'une théorie semble dénuée de sens la
notion de crédibilité de lois de la
physique semble pouvoir être qualifié
ainsi aussi ou du moins plutôt que de la
crédibilité des lois de newton dans un
cadre pseudo bayésiens au moins il
semble qu'il soit plus pertinent de
parler de l'utilité des lois de newton
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que ces
lois sont souvent en effet utile surtout
l'école mais aussi quand il s'agit de
construire des ponts ou d'étudier la
physique des matériaux
il est souvent utile d'invoquer la
librairie lois de newton que celles ci
soient enregistrés dans votre machine ou
dans votre cerveau une telle librairie
semble utile pour concevoir des théories
à la somme 9 fiable mais il est
intéressant de noter qu'elle n'est pas
toujours nécessaire
en effet parfois l'observation de
phénomènes émergents par exemple en
mécanique des fluides ou en physique des
plasmas peut être directement analysés
par des algorithmes par exemple de
machine learning qui pourrait être
capable de meilleures prédictions sont
jamais faire appel aux lois de newton
après tout pour savoir où un ballon va
tomber un joueur de football ne résout
pas une équation différentielle je pense
pas que pogba a résolu une équation
différentielle dans cette image les lois
de newton sont
utile mais il ne semble pas y avoir de
sens à dire qu'elles sont indispensables
pour effectuer des prédictions
bref pour les capitaux
les deux premiers points on n'a vu
qu'une théorie à la solomonoff devais
parier sur des données numérisées
possiblement observable en langage
mathématique on parle de loi de
probabilité sur ces données en un sens
ceci caractérise en fait davantage les
théories bayésienne que les théories à
la solomonoff l'énorme coup de génie de
seulement 9
ce fut intégré un troisième principe à
savoir la calculabilité des théories de
façon intrigante
on peut voir ce principe comme une
formalisation des idées du riou
souvenez-vous dans l'épisode 2 33 on a
vu que fuel pensait que le principe
d'uniformité rythme était critique à
l'induction
on a aussi surtout reformuler cette
uniformité risme à l'aide de la notion
de loi ou de règles de calcul et même
plus précisément à travers la notion
d'algorithmes dit autrement
qm affirmé que l'induction ne pouvait
être justifiée qu'en vertu de
l'existence d'un algorithme qui est
expliquée au moins partiellement
certaine régularité des données
observées et bien le génie de seulement
9 c'est tout simplement d'inclure
naturellement cette notion d'uniformité
risme en exigeant des théories qu'elle
soit algorithmique et aurier à la somme
c'est donc un algorithme qui décrit une
loi de probabilité sur les données ceci
étant dit on peut fournir une autre
explication beaucoup plus pragmatique à
cette exigence de solomonoff si on en
croit la thèse de church turing justifié
notamment par le théorème de gandhi dont
on a parlé avec gilles dowek notre
univers physique semble nous reste un
drap des opérations uniquement
calculable dans ce contexte toute
théorie pragmatique se doit d'être
calculable quoi qu'il en soit on a
maintenant tous les ingrédients
nécessaires pour comprendre la notion
centrale à la réflexion de solomonoff
une théorie à la solomonoff et n'est
plus ni moins une loi de probabilité
calculable sur l'ensemble des suites
binaire et ça je pense c'est l'une des
plus génial définition de toute
l'histoire des sciences et de la
philosophie
oui car avec ça on a maintenant tout ce
qu'il faut pour formaliser naturellement
le rasoir d'occam pour définir
précisément l'induction de selon mme
roth et pour ainsi enfin disposer d'une
solution complète aux fameux problème de
l'induction c'est ta vidéo